houle on termine avec le second volet de
notre série de reportages d'été sur les
sites touristiques de midi-pyrénées ce
soir thomas dandois et nicolas joxe vous
invite à un voyage leur de toulouse le
toulouse caché avec ses hôtels
particuliers ou ses cours intérieures
voici donc le portrait de ces îles à
traire le regard d'une guide fait
partager sa passion aux touristes depuis
maintenant 26 ans regardez cela s'
inquiète au coeur d'un magnifique
puisque tous les jours à 15h sonia ruiz
la dame en bleu entraîne le visiteur au
coeur de l'histoire deux heures ou pas
cap ses dents dures aux deux heures
pourront voir le bout c'est la direction
que nous allons partir
et
nous avons ce type de courrier qui est
très original à que nous appelons les
clochers
m
d'un côté trois temps tout en bois
après une furie l'étape par la rue du
taur de passage obligé l'église romane
des édifices rendement du grand sud
ouest de la france
un défi sur le plus bon allez je vais
dire le plus beau pourquoi pas 17h30 la
visite est terminée mais cette fois
sonia lève le voile sur les trésors
cachés du vieux toulouse de tout le
monde les arrière-cours celui du détail
oublié ya un moment je vous invite à me
suivre au bout de ce couloir tout noir à
ce qui est agréable ici c'est la
surprise de trouver un restaurant
installé dans la cour d'un ancien hôtel
particulier du 16e siècle que vous avez
là on fait un mur superbe mur de briques
à l'image de ce qu'est toulouse une
ville de briques et une ville rose
depuis une cinquantaine d'années depuis
que les toulousains ravalent leur façade
et mettre la brique apparente alors
qu'elle ne l'était pas à l'origine mais
bon aujourd'hui nous aimons ces briques
nous avons score de toulouse si élégant
si doux ça fait 26 ans que je guide dans
cette ville toujours avec la même
passion avec le même enthousiasme c'est
une ville dont on ne peut pas se lasser
ce petit balcon un petit balcon qui a
été reconstitué à l'identique par des
compagnons charpentiers puisque cette
maison avait été construite par un
compagnon charpentier quatre lettres en
bois à vouvoyer se détache végéter union
valeur et gloire au travail la devise
des compagnons charpentiers chaque jour
davantage chaque jour davantage je
m'émerveille de vivre dans une ville et
je connais rendent à et je connais
barcelone que ce sont peut-être deux
villes dans lesquelles j'aurais pu vivre
mais je reviens toujours à vers toulouse
dans cette cour de l'hôtel particulier
toulouse or rien n'a bougé depuis
plusieurs siècles encore aujourd'hui ici
le travail des architectes prend des
allures de performance comme c'est
escaliers dit l'escalier suspendu le
miracle c'est que le madrier extérieur
ne s'appuient sur rien c'est donc un
escalier suspendu qu'à 400 ans qui a été
utilisé depuis 400 ans
pour sonia ruiz et donc 26 ans de vie
26 ans de murs roses et jamais de
lassitude car quand on aime toulouse
c'est comme la mort d'une personne
plus vous la regardez plus vous la
trouvez belle plus vous l'étudier plus
vous la comprenez plus vous l'aimez plus
vous la fait partager
c'est comme ça